[Music]
hi guys it's Quinn here if you
appreciate my content consider hitting
the like buttons the only way the
YouTube algorithm notices me for those
of you that are interested my graphic
novel the LIE behind the star launched
on Indiegogo and it is funding now check
it out Link in the
description the three body problem
series is one of the best trilogies of
science fiction books that I've read in
recent years but in this video we will
be discussing its spin-off Redemption of
time Redemption of time was written by
Basel and continues the storyline of the
three-body problem Universe it mainly
follows the character Tian Ming the only
character in the original series to ever
make direct contact with the
tricin Redemption of time describes his
time among the tricin and how he was
visited by a powerful entity which gave
him knowledge about the nature of the
universe in this video we will mainly
discuss the nature of the original
universe and how it began to collapse in
Redemption of time we learned that the
original 10-dimensional Universe before
it begin to collapse was constructed
upon energy exchange between photons it
was literally a Universe of light all
particles and antiparticles were formed
from photons and their Mutual
Annihilation resulted in yet more
photons thus everything occurred at the
speed of light which was infinite even
more marvelously because particles and
antiparticles balanced each other out
the total energy level of the universe
was zero this was an incredible state of
symmetry and the foundation of the
emergence of intelligence in the
10-dimensional
universe matter
life sentience civilization in this
edenic universe everything was part of
the same whole all matter possessed life
all life possessed sentients and all
sentients existed in a state of
harmonious
civilization in the original Universe
all of creation existed in a state of
Perfect Harmony in this original
Universe the speed of light was infinite
it had slowed with each Dimension
collapsed to its current rate in the
Third Dimension the state of life in
this universe could not be described in
normal language Tian Ming was given what
the book refers to as ID abstractions a
form of language which could communicate
the proper nuances and subtleties of the
original 10-dimensional
Universe it is mentioned that the triin
did not have the ability to perceive ad
the abstractions Tian Ming learns that
the 10-dimensional universe itself was
alive and our three dimensional Universe
was its shriveling
corpse unlike the three-dimensional
Universe in which lonely Stars hung in
the vast emptiness of space the entire
universe was a living being all life was
but a part of this Grand life and all
intelligence but a component of the
highest intelligence the Dark Forest
state was an impossibility for this
Transcendent being of unified matter and
spirit in this original state of
existence individual presence was
seamlessly harmonized with the universe
and yet within the 10-dimensional
universe there was the lurker who sought
to darken the 10-dimensional universe
ending the adic age the story of the
lurker obviously is in reference to the
biblical stories found in the Book of
Genesis the 10-dimensional universe was
conscious an ultimate being essentially
God the lurker was a part of it who
rebelled against its ruler essentially
Lucifer the biblical reference is not
exclusive to the spin-off either in the
original series the 10-dimensional
universe is referred to as the identic
age multiple times a clear reference to
the Garden of Eden where Lucifer's
actions led to the fall of
mankind the universe had collapsed from
10 Dimensions to nine a traitorous child
of the edenic age had committed
matricide against the source of its life
of the infinite number of
consciousnesses that collectively formed
the master a single Consciousness
suddenly launched a rebellion leading to
the dimension reduction of the universe
caught off guard the master could
neither stop the Revolt nor understand
it if a child still within the womb
decided to attack the mother from within
how could the mother have been prepared
for it and that was how the lurker
succeeded the lurker actions were not
only incomprehensible to tan Ming but
also to the master Consciousness that at
once spanned the entire Cosmos how could
anyone who experienced the vibrancy of
that world tolerate The Emptiness and
crudeness of the three-dimensional
Universe he found it even more
incomprehensible that the lurker would
wish to destroy such a beautiful world
in harmony how vicious and crazed was
such evil then he witnessed the moment
of Destruction in a corner of this
universe life's light suddenly blinked
out leaving a small patch of Darkness
like a drop of Ink on Fresh white paper
at first the darkness seemed minor but
it quickly spread at the speed of light
turning the whole t-dimensional universe
pitch black even though the destruction
happened super fast literally at
infinite speed it followed a clear order
of events tion Ming decoded the details
through what the book calls IND the
abstractions describing it without our
threedimensional language would be
basically impossible but think of it
like a picture made of a bunch of domino
tiles standing up they all fell but you
can still make out the flattened picture
in an instant the universe collapsed
from 10 Dimensions to 9 this event while
catastrophic did not utterly destroy the
life of the 10 Dimension as with
Dimension collapses on lesser dimensions
on lesser beings instead the collapse
split them into separate conscious NES
the nine-dimensional universe resembled
a flawed version of the 10-dimensional
universe akin to a cracked egg drawing
parallels between the Chinese myth
wherein segments of the god pangu's body
transformed into the sun moon and
mountains and rivers postmortem the
nine-dimensional universe originated
from a deceased state of the
10-dimensional
universe despite its current innate
state it served as a Battleground where
numerous lives contined to clash
essentially it retained the essence of a
battlefield the book describes the
nine-dimensional universe as a cosmic
City in Ruins marred by the ravages of
war and
confusion as the process of Dimension
reduction neared its conclusion remnants
of the once expansive 10-dimensional
Universe fiercely resisted in this clash
between Darkness and Light brilliant
Rays erupted their intensity surpassing
even the radiance of the milk way the
book mentions and it actually uses an
analogy comparing a candle to the full
power of the sun amidst this Cosmic
struggle a significant portion of
entities retained memories and
civilizations inherited from the
decaying 10-dimensional realm and United
by a collective Endeavor they sought to
breathe life back into the fading
Dimensions though it is mentioned that
some succumb to the deceptive Allure of
the lurker betraying their Cosmic kin by
aligning themselves with with the forces
of the opposition this section of the
story also mirrors the biblical story of
Lucifer who was ultimately cast out of
Heaven along with several Fallen Angels
who had taken his side now all of this
is described to tion Ming through idea
abstractions so we're meant to imagine
that we are reading a version of the
truth that has been extremely dumbed
down to work with our human language
upon receiving all of this information
tianming actually comes to a revelation
about the original Universe a re ation
of a paradoxical and near
incomprehensible nature If Only They had
lived in the 10-dimensional universe
where the speed of light was infinite
wait a barely formed thought emerged in
tiam Ming's mind soon coming into focus
a key Point whose familiarity had caused
him to ignore its significance until now
how long has the three-dimensional
Universe existed he gazed at sofan
intently about
1,894 million years said San how long
did the four-dimensional universe exist
about 1 million years what about the
five-dimensional
universe 161 years and the
six-dimensional universe 90 days and 11
hours 7 dimensional 2 minutes and 3
seconds 8 dimensional 12 milliseconds
edimensional 31 milliseconds Tian Ming
suppressed his Rising excitement and
asked the final question what about the
10-dimensional
universe unexpectedly sofon was silent
for a moment before she said forever
there was no time in the 10-dimensional
universe of course Tian Ming muttered
infinite speed infinite efficiency
everything completed from the start
finished in an instant without the
passage of any time it was a universe
without time the original universe had
only lasted for a single instant and yet
it lasted forever it was a realm Beyond
Time truly each descending Dimension
would last longer and longer before
finally decaying the revelations about
the original 10-dimensional Universe its
collapse and the subsequent formation of
the nine-dimensional realm serves as a
compelling extension to Lan's original
story in my opinion The Narrative
conveyed to Tian Ming through ad
abstractions challenges our conventional
understanding of time and AD
abstractions themselves are a
fascinating concept Tian Ming's
realization of the Timeless nature of
the 10-dimensional universe also adds
complexity to the overarching narrative
it promotes contemplation on the
potential transient nature of our own
three-dimensional reality Redemption of
time also does a pretty good job of
expanding upon the philosophical
dimensions of the three body problem
universe and it doesn't stop there in
future videos we will discuss some of
the other interesting aspects of
redemption of time including an
exploration of one of the oldest
surviving civilizations in the universe
singer race who in the original series
launched a dimension strike against our
solar system collapsing it into two
Dimensions but that's it for now guys
thanks for watching and as I mentioned
in the beginning the Indiegogo for my
new graphic novel campaign is launching
right now and it will be going for the
next 25 days or so if you are interested
in supporting the channel by supporting
this graphic novel then click the link
in the description thank you so much
[Music]
guys
now